The Walking Dead certainly isn't known
for being a feel-good show and despite
the season 6 finale featuring watchman's
the comedian as negan it was still
anything but funny I'm Simon and this is
your zombie news update the walking dead
season 6 finale ended with one hell of a
cliffhanger and some fans aren't too
happy about it Robert Kirkman creator of
The Walking Dead has discussed it before
but now he says he isn't sorry for the
reaction it's gained from fans in an
interview of Entertainment Weekly
Kirkman said that although he knew there
would be a reaction he and the rest of
the production team didn't quite realize
exactly how big it would be we knew that
there would be a reaction we probably
didn't anticipate it would be so big but
cliff hangers are supposed to elicit a
reaction I mean that's what they're
designed to do so to a certain extent it
did its job it may be did its job a
little too well but I think people that
have invested in six years of the show
may not be happy about that cliffhanger
and I think that's a completely valid
response and I completely respect their
opinion I'm not sorry that we did it I
don't regret that we did it because
executive producers Scott M gimbal and I
we're trying to tell a story and that's
what we and the entire creative team
decided to do but it is what it is we're
working that much harder to come back
for Season 7 and make sure that the
payoff is worth the dread of the
uncertainty that we've given you over
the months that we're on break
unfortunately for fans no premiere date
has been announced for the Walking Dead
Season seven though it's believed to
start this year I doubt anyone was happy
but were you satisfied with the season
six cliffhanger let me know in the
comments or come find me on Twitter I'm
at the j connaught thanks for watching
and for all your entertainment news keep
it gamespot
you